hey Chris Hogan here I've spent a lot of
time traveling speaking and talking with
people all around the country a topic
that continues to get me fired up is the
self-made millionaire and their success
story
I've even devoted segments of my podcast
retire inspired so talking with these
self-made millionaires we're diving into
the life of someone who's reached
millionaire status one step at a time
over time all right people let's do this
the next episode of millionaire starts
right now
my name is Ron I'm originally from
Oakland California
moved down there at the age of about
seven during the military right out of
high school spent six years in the Air
Force got out and got into food business
managed brochure stores I went to work
for a company called Cal Tech citrus I
stayed with them for about 26 years
retired compared to 75 and Here I am if
I inherited anything it was wisdom of my
father we were taught at an early age
doesn't grow on trees and a job we're
doing is we're doing right and word is
your bond and integrity is so important
and just the fundamentals of functioning
in life and I found that those seeds
that were planted who've got to be
extremely valuable I did not go to
college and I think that's also
important I think people put a
tremendous amount of emphasis on going
to college without truly understanding
their gifts and their talents and
maximizing on that but we grew up also
in a house where can't never did
anything I never could say to my father
I can't you try if you fail you learn
why you fail and you try again so my
name is military it was no big deal I
mean I graduated from Rush you trust
reforms I think so often we say we set
out to do something I think we just put
our nose to the grindstone and we work
at work we start seeing the benefits of
that accomplishment the advancements and
it starts accumulating you have to you
do have to have a goal you have to be
aware cognizant of the fact that you're
going to some place I try to manage my
time like I manage my money it has to
serve a purpose so if you if you stay
focused on something the simplicity of
it is that you are constantly moving in
that direction your limitations are I
believe for most people within
themselves and it wasn't necessarily how
much I made is what I did with what I
mean
and I lived well within my means and
never ever went beyond so I didn't
happen to dig myself out of a hole I
think that's a message a lot of people
have to understand is living their wage
learning the difference between wants
and needs what are the limitations lie
in you in your surroundings your
circumstances and what can you change to
make a difference and I still say to
everyone if they live within their means
they're focused and defined with their
objectives they can do wonders and
that's because they refuse to accept the
status quo to me I think that's it
there's just too many people who kind of
give up and quitters never win and
winners never quit my challenge with a
lot of people is getting them to believe
in themselves you can do it because
again can every day
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]